so by way of introduction 11 years ago
Microsoft research open sourced fast
limb which is a genome-wide Association
tool kind of a statistics tool that
works on genomic data it's mostly in
Python but some of the parts that needed
to be super fast or the needed yeah file
reading especially that needed to be
super fast were written in C plus
three years ago I retired in one of my
projects is to maintain this so the
first thing I did was I upgraded from
the project from python 2 to Python 3
and then there were some user requests
just for a standalone uh
file reader the file formats called
plink bed format and so I turned that
into its own
package out of the out of the Fastlane
package
two years ago I don't know if you've had
things on GitHub and you have continuous
integration you don't make any changes
and then all of a sudden uh everything's
failing and you don't it's like I didn't
do anything and what had happened was
that some version of probably numpy was
using
was pulling in an openmp library and my
project also had an openmp library and
they were different versions so without
me doing everything anything the project
that used to work stopped working and
this wasn't the first time I'd had
problems with the uh openmp which we'll
talk about it's a c plus runtime
for doing data parallel work
uh so I'd gotten interested along with
python and another even newer language
called rust and it got me thinking about
maybe I could replace the C plus plus
using openmp with rust and rust has a a
data Library parallel Library called
rayon and over that course of doing that
port
nine rules could call them suggestions
but that sounds too wishy-washy so we'll
call them rules uh
yeah and
So reading the plink bed format the DNA
data it's this is DNA data so we have
some number of users maybe a thousand
maybe a million and we have some number
of DNA locations maybe 50 000 maybe a
million uh maybe 10 million
each value can be conceptually thought
of as missing zero one or two so we only
need two bits to represent the
individual values on the file in the
file format for this but when we use
this inside python we want it to be a
nice numpy array so we tell it that we
want it as an INT 8 or a float 32 or a
float 64. and very important because
this file can be really big but because
it's laid out in a very regular fashion
we can specify that we only want a
subset of the DNA locations and or we
only want a subset of the of the
individuals and just read that subset
and get a nice numpy array also along
with the numpy array there's also some
metadata so for the DNA locations which
are called Snips we have a name for the
snip and we also have some position
information which chromosome the Snips
in and two numbers that are two
different ways of saying where in the
chromosome it is and for individuals
for some reason the creators of this
data format thought that individuals
should be identified with
two strings an individual ID and a
family ID and we put those together and
we get a unique ID for each individual
um so
let me do yeah I hope I meant to ask
some questions so how many people here
have written any kind of python
extension in C or C plus plus or
whatever okay good how many people have
heard of rust
oh good wow and how many people have
actually like programmed even the
simplest thing in Rust and played with
it okay that's actually more than I was
expecting uh this will be an easier sell
than I thought so the reason we write uh
python extensions is because while
python is a readable flexible uh great
language Sometimes some of the things we
want to do it's not fast enough to do
for us traditionally we would then write
those core parts that needed to be
faster and C or C plus plus
that would get us the speed we wanted
but then we're bringing in all the
memory safety issues and maybe just the
aggravation of programming in uh in C
plus plus rust is a language that is
easier to program than C plus plus but
it is still 10 times harder to program
uh than python the reason
we'll put up with that is because it's
as fast as C and and C plus plus uh
moreover because it's a newer language
it has a nice uh infrastructure so
document comment uh
standards ways of formatting standard
ways of putting uh comments in your
documentation standard ways of testing a
standard place to have packages
versioning is way better than C plus
plus and I think better than python
because the versions you actually use
get
locked in and recorded and it can put
together things even when the versions
don't match it can still create a
program that runs its multi-processing
story is is really good
oh I should say if you have questions
while I'm speaking you can feel free to
raise your hand and interrupt me
um
and the reasoning you'll if you hear
about it you hear it getting recommended
as a replacement for new projects that
would have been done in C plus plus is
for uh memory safety
uh the bugs that cause so many security
problems in C and C plus plus and just
frustrations and maybe you're getting
the wrong answer because you messed up
something with your memory in C plus the
rust compiler catches
virtually all of those including those
related to running on multiple threads
and uh
makes you much much uh safer not for I
mean there's still effort for coding it
but at least when the code runs it's
very likely to be uh correct with
respect to to memory
so let me just give the smallest sample
of
rust code here
we can see that it looks more like C
plus it looks more like C than python
it's got uh curly braces it's fully
typed one thing that makes it
unique among the languages that I'd used
before is it it almost doesn't have any
notion of exceptions
instead when you have an error you're
expected to return a result type and the
result type might be a good answer an
okay answer or it might be an error
result
uh and first hear about that you're
going man that sounds crazy I've got to
think about these error results
um bubbling up it's not that bad and it
lets you do really important things like
when an error shouldn't be ignored it
makes sure that you uh that it's handled
that the com you could have set up so
the compiler would give you an error
message if you uh didn't do something
with the uh the error that was returned
this pound any input is an example of uh
of macros if you're familiar with C plus
plus macros they do everything at a text
level in theory they can do everything
but because of that they're just crazy
you can't know what they're going to do
in uh
enrust the macros take an abstract
syntax tree the parse more or less a
parsed version of the program and run it
through a rust program and create
another abstract syntax tree and then
give it to the compiler so everything
that the macros do is still type checked
all right
uh in this example you can see a line
that says readers.lines that's an
example of an iterator very similar to
what we would have and then dot count so
that's something very similar to what
you would see in Python
um they're not quite as nice yet as
Python and python we have a yield
command and rust doesn't have that but
they're fine
and the best thing is compared to uh
Alternatives the compiler catches memory
errors like using memory after you've
freed it having a dangling pointer
rust has no null pointers there's no
none there's no null it's all done with
the type checking so you never have to
worry about
assuming uh doing the wrong thing
because you've been handed a nun
or or a null and uh because the memory
checks actually have implications as we
run on multi-threads it stops uh data
races when we're multi-threading so the
your multi-threading code is not a yeah
it's much more likely to be correct
I actually found a bug in my C plus code
when I ported it didn't it was a data
race so it didn't happen it probably
never happened but it could have
happened and I didn't know it until I
ported the code
uh
this is all based on an article I wrote
about a year and a half ago but I
updated last week so you can call nine
rules for writing python extensions in
Rust and you can find it on on
medium.com and towards uh uh data
science
and I should say the general approach
here is we're going to write a Python
program
a function a python function it's going
to call
a special runs rest function that we've
only defined to be convenient for python
to call and that translator function
we'll call what I'll call nice rust code
rust code that uses types and such
okay nine
rules
so you can put your rust code and your
python code in the same uh repository in
the same in the same folder conveniently
and coincidentally maybe they don't
interfere mostly if we create something
called bed reader in Python then we're
going to have a subfolder called
bedreader that's where most of our all
our python code will go by default rust
expects most of its code to be under a
folder called SRC so they can both go
there there's some general files your
readme's uh rust has a top level file
called cargo.com
instead of a setup file we'll see later
we're going to use uh Pi Project dot Tom
all but those can all live at the at the
top level and not interfere with each
other and work nicely together
so the nicest thing when I went to do
this is it turned out someone had
actually done all the hard work
they had created a combination of
libraries that I may be mispronouncing
matron and pi03
matron is a package they're Associated
together matching is what you see from
the python side you say pip install and
that uh gives you the ability to call
rust on the rest side rest packages are
called crates
we you say that you want to use the rest
crate
Pi 03 and then you can that lets you use
rust types and working together
you're set so
in my example mycargo.tomo is is my rust
list of dependencies
uh I bring in a popular error Library
I bring in
two libraries three libraries related to
interpreting uh numpy style arrays
people have already worked that that out
for us the rayon is the multi-threading
library that I talked about and then the
the pi 03 and we'll see the rest of this
in a little bit
so I mentioned the what I recommend is
that you write a nice python function
that calls a translator function in Rust
and then the rust function can call a
nice rust code so here's an example of a
translator function you can see at the
top it's got three macros these are from
PI 03 that set it up so it can be called
directly from
from python uh
we can in
put just the string
in this case a couple numbers a Boolean
a one-dimensional array and it knows
that this is going to be a numpy
one-dimensional array
uh
I think that's a numpy one dimensional
maybe it's a python list I actually
don't remember now
I think it's a one-dimensional python uh
numpy array yeah and then uh and uh
we're also going to in this case pass in
a two-dimensional python array and we'll
see about that vowel argument in a bit
and uh we're going to pass in a
parameter called num num threads which
for multi-threading is going to control
how many threads we uh we use and then
all this translator thing does is it
does a little bit of work to get the
type set up for rust and then it calls a
nice rust API that by this point in the
code I've written so that you could read
this file format nicely from uh from
rust also
and yeah that's all we need for the the
middle layer and we'll talk in a little
bit about uh error handling and and numb
threads
so there's probably a way
that you could have python call rust
have Russ allocate memory
and have it go
back to Python and have python own the
memory after that
I don't know what it is
what was much easier for me was just to
say I I'm uh in this case I'm having it
read data from a file into a numpy array
I know exactly how big the array should
be if the read works so I'm just going
to allocate it in Python
before I make the rest call
so this is the python excerpts from the
python code for uh for reading the
there's a type d-type says whether we
want it to be an N8 an f30 a floating 32
or a floating 64.
um it's I forgot to show it here but it
figures out in this case that it wants
to do the read f64 method and then it uh
in the python we just called this and
that'll call the function we saw uh
uh on on the previous page and we've
already allocated the memory so that
takes care of all my memory allocation
problems
in this case
so
uh we want nice error handling
for in both languages so we have to do
some translation uh
the uh where it says example one you can
see it trying to open a file and
creating a a buff reader this is a rust
code that question mark means that if
there was a error result from a file
open it would immediately return from
this function with the uh with the air
result in the error it would return is
called standard i o error the you know
the file's not there would be an example
of that
um in Rust you can take standard errors
and wrap them in your own error objects
so in this case I have an error object
called bed reader plus it has several
flavors one of the flavors is IO errors
and if it gets an i o error then that'll
pretty much automatically get
translated into a bed error plus type
so now
we have a bed error type plus type but
we would need a python error because our
users in Python don't want to see
uh
this weird rust thing they want to when
they try to open a file and the file
doesn't open they want a nice python
error so in Rust we can write a
converter into a type called Pi error Pi
error is defined by the pi O3 package
that we brought in and we can just go
through and do uh
pattern matching and it's like oh if
it's anything these errors having to do
with indexing then we'll return a a
python error index if it's an i o error
then we'll return a pi i o error which
is a standard python error class and if
it's anything else we'll translate that
into a python value error and in all
these cases whatever the error message
string is gets copied over
also so you should get errors from your
python users should see errors as good
as you would get if you'd written
everything uh in Python
and yeah I mean obviously you can also
if when you rushed you can Define your
own errors and those will get translated
over the same way
so uh doing the multi-threading
is very nice I used I originally thought
that rayon the multi threading Library
had no run time maybe it has a little
bit of run time but it's you don't have
to worry about it it's not like bringing
in openmp or something like that it gets
compiled in and it's not things just
work on on multiple threads uh it works
for I don't know you have a million DNA
locations and you want to find the
average of every DNA location that's
obviously easy to do in parallel it
makes it obviously easy to do it in
parallel just the way you uh uh want to
do the one
problem that I had with it is a lot of
it's a some methods assume that when
you're processing say columns in
parallel there won't be any errors
and there might be errors if I'm doing
things like finding the standard
deviation of a column but I can have
missing data
so if all the data is missing or there's
only one bit of data then the standard
deviation isn't defined and that's a
nice error users my users actually often
have bad data and they don't know it
until the program
comes back and replies that hey there
was a problem with the data and they go
oh yeah that's not the that's not the
data I thought I was giving it
so we need ways to capture those errors
and we've got uh two that I recommend
one is to use this method called
parallel bridge and that takes any
iterator that is serial and starts doing
everything on it in parallel
and then on top of that you can do a
method called try for each and try for
each we'll start things running in
parallel and if any of them fail as
quickly as it can not instantly it'll
stop the iteration and return one of the
errors and if nothing errors then
nothing errors and you're and you're
fine
another example uh I won't go into it
but this code takes a bunch of arrays
that all happen to be the same length
and Zips through them and it's doing all
that in parallel if there's a problem it
uh it's allocated and an array called
result which will mostly just be okay
okay okay okay
but if there was an error on any of
those it would put in an error message
so it can do all that in parallel when
it's done there'll be this result array
and then it can just do a quick scan
through that uh that error array and if
there's an error bubble that up and if
not everything
everything is fine
uh I
believe very strongly that users have to
be given control of the number of
threads that they're running on
sometimes they have to Coexist on with
other programs and they can't just take
over the whole machine
so rust rayon Library makes it possible
to do that but it made it kind of hard
so get the article copy this exact
function from the top
and then if you do that then you can
write your translation method you can
see it says down there it says create
pool which is that function we defined
right there
and then you just put a a Lambda an
evaluable expression uh inside and if
it's running inside that create pool
then whatever thread you set will will
will be enforced and on the python side
just for reusability the way I set
number of threads is maybe the user can
set it but it can be none if it's none
then I got a list of like five
environment variables that it looks at
like
mkl thread numb or something like that
and and some others that are commonly uh
commonly used
um
yeah here's a
so in Python if we want something to
work with an arrays of 8-bit integers
floats of 32 floats of 64. we pass
the arrays into our python function and
say plus or minus or divide and it just
works it's lovely
in Rust it's not going to be willing to
add
two arrays together if it doesn't know
exactly what type they are
at the beginning the way that it can
still offer some flexibility is with
generics a concept that we also have in
C plus plus and it means you can write
your array code to be generic for type T
where T is going to be
I8 F32 or f64
you still only have to write your
function
once make it generic and then the rust
compiler under the behind the scenes
will make three instantiations of it one
for each
uh type that it actually sees getting
used that actually gives us a problem
that the way that rust handles
supporting multiple types and python is
different the solution is that we make
three hopefully not too big translator
functions in Rust so we make one
function
to read I 8-bit integers one for
floating Point 32s and ones for uh float
64s
so our one Python program
calls one of those three
those three are explicitly there but
they're not very long they all call the
same
rust code generically so it's not
perfect but it's it's not terrible and
it gets us our type checking
um last rule
uh how to do tests there's a temptation
that us I'm I've written this uh this
extension for python python is
really easy to write tests for in so
maybe I should just do all my
tests for the rust code in Python
because what could be the easiest way to
write them
I don't think you should do that I think
you should take the effort to also make
uh the tests in Rust as if you were only
writing in Rust Russ has a nice
testing framework it's very similar to
Pi test and if you're using uh this is
visual studio if you're using visual
studio you'll even get a list of all the
rust tests that it can scan your code
and find
well that doesn't mean you shouldn't
also do the python testing
you should also do the python testing
and if you're in Visual Studio you'll
also get a nice list
of all the python tests and you should
just
uh test both and it's if you keep
everything in the same repository like I
recommend it you don't have to have all
your data files for your tests in
different places you can keep them in
one place in both both programs can get
a
so it's the last slide
rust is great for python extensions
I should have mentioned where does numpy
or not numpy uh
cython and number is that right
fit in I think if you could get those to
work those are like special purpose more
python-like fast things if you can get
them to work for your problem uh you
should probably just use them the reason
you want to use C plus plus or rust is
because you want a full General
programming language with lots of
libraries that can can do everything so
um so yeah we get the speed that we want
uh
there shouldn't be anything that runs
faster than this we get safe data
parallel multi-threading
people have already worked out all the
library so it knows about python numpy
arrays which is important in my case you
should follow these rules
when you do that you'll get
hopefully great code in both the Python
and the rust and in fact on the rust
side after getting this working at all I
decided to take the extra step and make
everything available as a nice rust
Library also I don't know how many
people
using rust directly to do bioinformatics
but I thought if anyone ever does
they'll be able to read blinkbed files
and it was an interesting exercise to
see how to move the API over and see if
I can make it as easy to use as I could
in Python I can talk about that if
anybody's interested and finally there
is an article that all this is mentioned
on
yeah so
um are there any questions
all right so we have about 15 minutes oh
perfect okay yeah please ask questions
maybe I talk too fast I'm gonna go over
there first and then I'll come back
all right
uh so
when you're talking about testing you're
saying that you should be testing both
your rust code and your python code and
I was just wondering it seems a little
inefficient to test like everything
should you just be testing like the
python interface yeah I would think that
would be enough the nice reason to make
the rust test do your unit test in Rust
if your work is in Rust is because then
you can like set break points and when
things go wrong you can go line by line
and see where things didn't work
um
sometimes I did do a little more than
that because python makes it so easy to
do I don't know integration tests and
quite crazy things where it's like what
if I started in this type and converted
to that type it's kind of a pain to
write all that
in Rust and in Python A lot of that kind
of testing becomes super easy so if it's
really easy to do then you know why not
do it in Python
okay so
um my question was uh so in Python when
you're coding you don't have to think
about like mutability or like God forbid
like lifetimes or anything I'm just a
couple of those words I'm sorry oh sorry
a little okay
um when you're coding in Python you
don't have to think about mutability uh
so how do you make like meaningful error
messages like from the translator or
like documentation for these like
Concepts that python programmers don't
have to like you said mutability yeah
yeah like when you when you're like uh
making a variable
um you have to say if it's going to be
changed or not right right so this
Library any of the errors that have to
do with some of the weird Rush not weird
but important things like mutability and
things like that the compiler catches
all those by the time it compiles and
the user is running it
those kinds of Errors should be
impossible for the user to hit
uh let me give a example make sure we're
talking about the right thing in um
in Python sorry in Rust if you tell it
that a variable is mutable is changeable
um
you only one thing that has a reference
to that variable
only one thing is allowed to have a
reference to that variable if you try to
have two things reference something
that's mutable you'll get a compiler
error and
um you it won't compile
um
at least the way that this called where
we called down to Ross that filled in
this array and then passed it up
now it's passed up to python it's just a
python ND array and python you know can
do whatever it would have done with it
before
I imagine there might be more
complicated
things you could be doing we're maybe
you're keeping rust objects and putting
them in a black box and giving them to
the python I haven't done that and I
don't know how hard it would be and if
that would
cause challenges with things like
mutability yeah
example that like we could find for
making a rust extension because uh this
code is all uh this bed reader code is
all on GitHub okay and referenced in the
article
thank you and I saw
coming back did you have it up first
there's plenty of time so I'll come here
hi uh python is this very idiomatic and
I tried doing rust
a while back and I made an array and
then I tried to populate that array and
read the array and it said you can't do
that so
um correct it's also rust is also very
opinionated and idiomatic just different
idioms
um
yeah it's not the only sense in the rust
is only easy to learn in the sense that
you compare it to C plus plus
uh if you can get away with writing as
much as you can in Python you know stay
in Python
and then do the things that need to be
in a very fast language in Rust and then
you just have to accept that it's going
to take a while to learn and become
productive in it
okay so the it's just a matter of
experience yeah and everybody I mean
there is good educational material uh
is this a saving grace that everybody
realizes that it's hard to learn so that
there's a lot of material to at least
give you a path
I mean you won't be alone
thank you
can talk a little bit about the unsafe
and why that was necessary
oh oh yeah so most code in Rust
uh you'll never
breast enforcement enforces memory
safety by default but if you want
something to be unsafe if you need
something to be unsafe like you I don't
know you're doing a low-level driver
in a microcontroller or something then
you put just the bit of code that needs
to be unsafe
in an unsafe statement with unsafe Open
Bracket it's code curly brackets I I
know what you're referring to I'm just
setting it up so most rust code is in
the safe space but you can Mark a little
bit to be unsafe way back
here
we had
one bit of code in the middle of the
page where it says unsafe
and that has something to do with the
interface between Python and rust uh
it's basically telling the rust compiler
to trust
that
taking this python memory and now having
it available in Rust is okay and the
compiler shouldn't complain that it
can't verify that it's okay
so you know I'm just following the
documentation from the library I was
using and it
and it's only one line so at least we
know where to look if they're or happen
to be problems
hey thank you for your talk it's really
interesting
um so working on a team full of python
developers in which we have some
situations in which python is too slow
to do what we want to do
um can you speak to the costs about
having a team running an owning code in
both Python and in Rust
uh
more expensive than just python but
cheaper than Python and C plus plus
I think I mean you can it might be
unfair because lots of people have
experience with C plus plus but C plus
plus keeps changing so if your C plus
plus code is you know done and working
then I guess you shouldn't rewrite it
called oxidizing you shouldn't change it
to rust
um there wouldn't be any reason to do
that but if your C plus plus is
frustrating you and if you hear that C
plus plus is going to add the feature
that you really need but it won't be
available till
the next release which will be three
more years
then maybe you should just do it in Rust
because you know you can just get the
features you need now like this nice
multi-threading Library
cool thank you
coming up to the front guys and then
about three minutes that way it'll give
you a five minute Shuffle time to the
next session remember to network
LinkedIn GitHub and uh check if there's
some free shirts available
okay
um I was kind of curious have you
considered any other languages other
than Russ like I was thinking maybe
Julia might be a good way to go faster
or uh uh no because I had any kind of
own reasons I was already using C plus
plus and you're like what's the most
similar and I was curious to learn it uh
okay we'll see and likewise uh number
and cython I didn't really fully
evaluate
um I don't know a ton about doing
non-python extensions do you have to
make considerations for targeting
different operating systems can you say
that again do you have to make
considerations for targeting different
operating systems uh rust is probably at
least as good as
um
python is I guess when I'm on this isn't
GitHub and uh
to make the wheel I'm making it for Mac
Windows Linux python
78910 so that's kind of annoying I've
got a binary
bit of code that's compiled 12. in 12
combinations but it's all automated so
it doesn't kill me if a user wants to
run the Mac on an M1 then I doubt it'll
work and if it does it won't be fast
like Mana what
hey I'm hoping for an idiomatic and
highly opinionated answer here sure um
it's recorded so I'll be held
responsible
so the rare times that numpy isn't fast
enough I've always I've pulled out my
book on psython and I have optimized
I've written stuff in C
do you think having gone through this
experience that this rust is a better
language for this than c for like the
sort of numeric stuff that typically
needs to be taken I don't think in speed
there'd be any difference at all it's
mostly that rust is a much newer
language than C so you can pull in
uh it's crates package the equivalent of
pip but working even more reliably so
you just have all the beauty of a kind
of modern of a modern language does the
um is the maintenance burden
significantly lower than the dot slash
configure make clean make install yeah
yeah
there's no make it's better than python
in that sense you say cargo
build cargo test and it does that you
say cargo upload I think is how it goes
to it's equivalent of Pi Pi so I think
it's even a little better than uh Python
and it's
infinitely better than uh using cmake
files or whatever the solution is now
it still unfortunately make files yeah
thank you thank you
all right any last questions
okay got one all right we're gonna make
yours the last one because then we're
gonna go into Shuffle time
uh this is more looking for your opinion
uh in terms of like the future I know
that uh the future releases of python
are promising to be much faster maybe
the python 4
.
um and I was just curious to see what's
your opinion in terms of like rust being
used in machine learning as well yeah
the faster python is the less they'll be
need for
um extensions but my mental model is we
have
python is the slowest but easiest to
read and write language then we have a
middle layer of C sharp and Java and
then we have the lowest level fastest
languages C C plus plus and rust python
might make it to being as fast as Java
and C sharp maybe it's going to be a
long time before it's as fast as C and C
plus plus
I think
all right let's give a round of applause
and thank you to Carl thank you
and you have